peng shuai attablé avec deux amis au
restaurant en pleine discussion avec son
entraîneur
la vidéo a été publiée sur twitter par
l'éditeur en chef du global times un
média proche du régime chinois sur une
deuxième vidéo on voit l'athlète de 35
ans entré dans le restaurant qui se
trouverait à pékin impossible de
certifier les enregistrements mais dans
la fenêtre une affiche sur laquelle
semble être inscrit la date du jour 20
novembre 2021 même si les vidéos
s'avérait bel et bien authentique ce
serait des preuves insuffisantes pour
s'assurer du bien-être de l'athlète sont
allés folle la probabilité que touche a
été orchestrée qui avait un scénario et
quand on lui a demandé de jouer un jeu
l'ancien ambassadeur du canada en chine
estime que ping chou et doit faire
l'objet de menaces sérieuses de la part
du régime chinois l'inquiétude grandit
autour du sort de l'athlète depuis sa
disparition il y a plus de deux semaines
l'ancien numéro un mondial du double a
disparu après avoir accusé sur internet
zhang gaoli un puissant ex responsable
du parti communiste d'agression sexuelle
depuis des photos d'elle qui n'ont pas
été authentifiées non plus ont été
publiés sur twitter réseau social
officiellement bloqué en chine pour ceux
qui s'inquiètent de son sort comme la
wta qui régit le tennis féminin mondial
ces preuves sont douteuses le pdg de la
wta s'est une nouvelle fois exprimé
après la publication des vidéos il écrit
je suis heureux de voir les vidéos
publiées par les médias d'état chinois
qui semblent montrer peine joué dans un
restaurant de pékin mais cette vidéo
seul est insuffisante
d'eau vont sauter sur l'occasion pour
demander des comptes au groupement
chinois pourtant que selon lui la vague
d'indignation sur le web de la part de
joueurs de tennis notamment n'empêchera
pas elle seule la chine de se tirer
d'affaires dans ce dossier ici levier
lefebvre radio canada montréal